Let's go next to our caller from the eight
Oh six area code. Who's calling today from
eight zero six
hello. Is this me?
Yes it is.
Oh, hello. David Auckland. I name is [inaudible].
I'm a, I'm a recent listener. You know, my
friend told me about the show cause I want
to learn more about politics. Yeah. Where
are you from? Thank you for taking my thoughts.
Oh, I'm in Texas right now, but I'm originally
from Columbia. You know what part of Poland?
Iowa. Oh, you don't know the Capitol, you
know? But anyways, so I've been watching the
election recently and you know, I'm really
upset about a caucus, you know? Well, so I
guess my, my question and you know, they're
releasing like some other results, but like
do you know why they didn't? Just a way to
like release them all at once, you know?
Well, there's two points of view on that.
One is that releasing nothing until they have
100% would be even more embarrassing because
it could be like five days. So that's one
part. That's the most innocent explanation.
Conspiratorial explanation would be they've
had close to 100% of the results for awhile,
but they selected 62% initially, later 71%
that were favorable to Pete boot edge edge
to give him a round of news headlines. That's
the more conspiratorial point of view. I don't
know the answer to be quite honest. Better.
Oh, okay. Okay. You know what? All right.
You know, I'm kind, kinda just like watching
like three news, hoping like, you know, they
get 100% later cause yes, I don't get why
they're like talking about it and it's like
they don't have the full results.
Yes. So we're all, we're all concerned about
this and it is a big ball drop. And you know,
I think Iowa doesn't even deserve to go first.
I think the first to vote should be a primary
anyway, not a caucus. And I think that this
disaster in Iowa justifies saying in 2024
there's no, Iowa goes first anymore.
Oh yeah. I don't even, like, I didn't even
know where Iowa was.
Okay.
I'm trying to understand like where the country
is and everything, you know, since I've been
here.
How long have you been into the U S
Oh, I've been here, you know, uh, two years
now. You know, we didn't want him to come
here for a long time, but you know, I, you
know, I said what happened? Know when you
have a wife and a kid, it gets kinda tossed,
you know, and they came with you. But anyway.
Oh yes, yes, yes. My wife, you know, she doesn't
really like, we're not doing too good right
now together, but you know, I still love my,
my wife and my kids and voluntary and I'm
telling them, I'm telling the like this country
through even though.
And do you, are you interested in going back
to Columbia?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'll, I'll, I'll stick with it here, you know.
Got it.
All right. A real pleasure on goof stuff.
I appreciate the phone call.
Well, thank you David. Document. Okay. But
all right, we'll talk to Pedro later. Very
interesting phone call. Let's take a quick
break. Don't hang up. If you are holding,
we will go right back to the phones after
this short break.